hey everyone it's my photos welcome to
the older phones market analysis for
Wednesday October 4th 2017 another day
another new high in the equities and you
know this is nice to see the market
getting some movement the dollar and
Treasuries were didn't get much movement
I think we're a little changed we got a
lot on the calendar this this week with
obviously Friday you've got the non-farm
payrolls coming out so let's just jump
into it there's a few classic examples
of order flow analysis buys and sells
today so this disclaimer is something I
read every day this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
should not be considered a solicitation
to buy or sell a futures contract or
make any other type of estimate decision
futures train contain substantial raise
because not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing once by natural
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results as usual tools used in this
presentation are the order flows trader
volume footprint chart the Delta scalper
and the price rejected which are two
additional tools that I created to read
the order flow for you okay so coming
into the u.s. session equities were very
tight range again just like just like
yesterday if not even a little bit
slightly a little bit tighter actually
I'm coming to eight o'clock and you know
we make this new low just after 8
o'clock around 8 o'clock 25 29 and a
half hour high for the day is 25 30
three and a quarter so if you're not
even talking a four point range that's
how quiet it was cash opened and well
here out on this on this low you have a
divergence no ratio you know the Delta
scalper giving you a signal you got
volume at 12:41 the first time 86 the
second time but after the cash open
you've got you know price rejector
you've got a divergence you've got a
ratio you know couple that with the last
volume that you saw in the first time
and you know it's a bit bullish it's a
bit bullish here right after the cash
open and I think I'll keep in the back
of my mind we've only got a four point
range just about and you know what can
you expect for the market
if you expecting a rally from the low to
the high it's not going to take much but
what happens is we start to rout
we start to rally from you know the 30
and a half area just up to the 32 and a
half come back down hit the low make new
lows and on the second time I shy on
this new low here at 8:48 when you got
you've got a ratio you've got a
divergence you got the price I sorry the
Delta scalper giving you a buy here
which is you know what you want to see I
mean yes you had it sort of here earlier
it did a rally
yeah rallied a little bit I mean I'm not
gonna say is the greatest rally in the
world but you still got a little bit of
move maybe you could have got something
out of that move and then but you got
another buy signal here you know even
though you made that new low on the new
low you got another buy signal what
happens is it starts crawling along you
know like I guess
I don't you want to call that type of a
centipede or something it's just sort of
loping along not really doing anything
it's not until about 10:30 that boom the
buying really starts to come in but is
there any reason to be selling in here
no nothing in the order float on you to
get out of your position or get short
not not in the least there's nothing
telling you that and if you're a patient
I said you know yesterday you had to
wait a long time for the move to happen
in the espys but when it happened it was
kind of a nice move so you're talking a
move from you know the low here at 25
you know just above 25 29 if you get
along around 25 30 what happens is you
finally get a nice rally and gets all
the way up here where you get the Delta
scalper giving you a sell signal up at
25 36 this Delta scalper fails you make
a new high just up here at 11:30 you
start to come off and you just sort of
go sideways the rest of the session but
what was the signal what was the trade
of the day whether it was two trades
there's this one here you know you can't
overlook it even though it's a small
move it's a legitimate trading
opportunity you got to take it it's not
a great move but it's a move but then
here again you know even if you know now
again I know some people will take this
move right it all the way up here let it
come down here still be in the position
get stopped out and then send me a nasty
email
trading methods sucks well you know why
didn't you take something out of this
when it was in your favor or trailer
stop - at least break even and I mean it
just comes down to knowing how to trade
I guess but you know even if you took a
loss there okay even if you took a loss
of a point or so you know a point in a
tick so you know five ticks you got
another opportunity here and if you're
patient and you held it you're rewarded
you know you make back what you lost on
the first trade if you took a loss on
the first trade so that was the SPS
today okay so this next Mike I'll talk
about is crude oil so this is the eight
range crude chart and you know we
started coming in making new highs as
New York started getting in and you can
see 611 new high six forty eight new
high seven twenty new high I hit a new
high here at eight twenty eight and you
got the Delta scalper coming in giving
you a nice sell signal up here just
right off the high around the 50 you
know 50 36 50:34 area you know again
it's one of these things with Delta you
know if you're not using Delta in your
trading you're missing out on a very
valuable piece of information you can
see how the market sold off from this
you know 30 area down into the teens
before the number came out you know the
inventory numbers came out today it was
Wednesday I could market going fast
market mode not a lot of liquidity
you know 948 you got another sell signal
here with the Delta scalper I don't know
if I take it a little bit close to the
number I mean it's closer to ten o'clock
than it is to 9:30 maybe you'd be
interested in taking it if he did you
know you got me very fast and it made a
quick move down to 38 one sideways a
little bit poked out into the mid 20s
before rallying back up to this new
swing high here you got a racial bounds
low I don't know there's some volume at
the top of this bar so I find this bar
kind of you know acting as a resistance
area and then you got Delta scalper
coming in again right after this swing
high and it just falls over here so
again you know maybe you're not
convinced that this is a swing high you
know then you get a delta scalper coming
in at this point you should be sort of
leaning towards getting short I mean
there's no reason to believe that we're
going to
solve a sudden rally and and go higher
if you're going to be read as position
to something it's to be short not not
long I mean what do you see do you see
any buying going on in here any
aggressive buying no in fact you see a
zero print in there you've seen
imbalances and balances and balances and
balances and you know then the selling
really picks up on this move down 174 to
69 1000 the Delta is what I'm looking at
here stacks on and balance you got a
little bit of a bounce here with the
with the green candle but then you just
continue on down just keep on selling
down down down down down so again you
know if if you're not using Delta write
this Delta scalper right it's a tool I
created to analyze the Delta I said I
used to analyze this in my head okay
before I realized hey why don't I just
have my programmer program it for me and
so he did I mean so that that's why I
get these indicators programmed you know
people try and think that out you're you
know it's like thing with like a moving
average right you just taking an average
of prices manipulating y'all times any
people got all these different types of
moving averages looking at you know
weighted moving average exponential
moving average why not just learn how to
trade you know I mean I don't need the
Delta scalper it's just it's designed
just to do the calculation that I would
just do in my head I would just look at
you know what price are sorry what the
market was doing you know what's the
price action right now what's Delta
analyzed that I'd normally I would do
it's just like these these ratios here I
used to do these calculations in my head
and then I decided hey why don't I just
pay some guy to program it and so I
don't have to do that you know just make
my life a lot easier and I did and
that's how this whole order flows com
software a company came about you know
was because people I started talking to
people about it and like hey that's
interesting you know can I can you sell
it to me you know because you know
people don't want just people are shy I
guess just to ask for it for free you
know so that's why I get these things
programmed is you know these are tools
that I've been using for years right
instead I using to them in my head
though I said hey when I just didn't
want you just pay somebody to to program
it up there for ya okay so a bit of a
slow mover you know there's an
old-school guy I'm a clicking
point-and-click guy I'm not a let's just
program everything in automated like
that you know I but I do like to have
some signals automated in the sense that
you know it takes some of the the work
off my shoulders
alright then I don't have to sit there I
could analyze a few more markets and do
everything that way so anyway you know
you got a nice signal here and you know
you talk in the 50 40 50 44 50 45 area
what happens when we get a beautiful
beautiful move down to new lows down
here to 49 76 and what do you get Delta
scalper giving you a buy here so it's
doctor scalpers reading all this here
and this is just beautiful right it's a
nice move down and look at these deltas
- thousand - 783 - 823 - 260 ok then
Delta scalper kicks off here he got
positive Delta of 907 and they said if
you're just looking at this you know you
might be thinking hey this market is
probably still going lower we still got
some selling but by analyzing the Delta
and understanding what's happening in
the Delta you realize that no you know
it's actually shifting from a supply
driven market you know with a lot of
selling to a demand driven market with a
lot of buying and what happens is this
market starts to move up from the 49 90s
all the way back up above you know 50
bucks 50 you know into the teens again
here's the Delta scalper that failed
then you're going to the close right
here and it's where we are in the
evening session so there was some decent
trades we had this was a nice trade to
have obviously this one big trade right
here was it was nice to have and you
know there was one or two trades you
know this this one here at 8:30 until
you know until 9:00
ish 9:15 is it's okay I said it's that's
not the monster move that you like but
hey if you could you know get a quick
trade in before the API numbers what did
I just say before the numbers I got a
lot of stuff on my mind before the
inventory numbers come out you know from
you know 15 18 cent move you know hey
that that's great before the inventory
numbers come out you don't want to be in
a position while then the numbers are
released in the market goes into a fast
mark
but still you know there were some
trades to be had here's some decent
trades to be had in the crew today all
right so this is bonds and bonds
interesting you know kind of quite quiet
market a lot of these markets have been
quiet coming into the morning session so
a four o'clock you made your low here
you got a bullish ratio you got price
reject your giving you a buy signal you
got all the bottles indicators giving
you a buy signal rallies up to this high
Delta scalper you got a divergence
kicking in market sells off excuse me
get down here just off the low you got
delta scalping giving you a buy this one
doesn't work out then obviously you got
the number that came out there at nine
and you started making new lows new lows
new lows 923 and then here 1125 you've
got a divergence you got a point of
control towards the bottom he and next
bar you got your a ratio and you got the
Delta scalper so you got a lot of stuff
going on here that's telling you hey
this market is now exhibiting buying
coming in right here you see all selling
right imbalance in balance and balance
and balance and balance but things are
changing that's why the Delta scalper
you know it's designed to pick up these
changes pretty quick and what happens is
this market rallies rallies from 16 all
the way up to you know the clothes and
we closed at about 26 so you know that's
that's a nice tent take move you don't
you just get half of that for less than
half you know that's four or five ticks
four or five ticks that's that's good
already in the bonds but it's you know
Delta's copper is designed to pick up
these changes these subtle changes that
are happening that maybe you know to the
naked eye you can't see so easily
especially if you're not used to reading
order flow to see and it happened in the
order flow that it's getting that move
okay so thanks for watching this video
to learn more about trading software
using this presentation and how you can
succeed with order flow trading visit my
web site order flow is calm and go to
the Delta scalper comm website to learn
more about the Delta scalper thisit's a
great tool to help you in your training
especially if you're new to order flow
it's a great way to ease into order flow
and add
you know a different element to your
trading so thanks everyone have a great
day bye-bye